15 mars 2020 attrape le maire sortant
apprend qu'il ne se classe qu'en
troisième position à l'issue du premier
tour des élections municipales
guy malandain devancé de 18 voix par
othman nasri mais surtout de 446 voix
par son ancien adjoint ali rabais la
gauche se divise un peu plus dans cette
commune sans pour autant profiter à la
liste d'union du principal opposant
trois mois après le scrutin les forces
en présence n'ont pas changé ni leurs
principaux points de programme
chacun espère donc une mobilisation des
électeurs dans cette commune où
l'abstention est souvent élevé au début
de crise sanitaire a amplifié le
phénomène avec seulement 34 % de votants
ce dernier week-end hiver les quelques
trente deux mille trappistes dont le
revenu médian est presque deux fois
moins élevé que les autres habitants du
département et qui attendent pourtant
des réponses à de nombreux dossiers à
commencer par celui de l'éducation
retour à la semaine de quatre jours
encore accompagnement ps colère on
rappellera que 25 % les habitants au
moins de 15 ans la gestion du logement
occupera également la prochaine équipe
municipale comment protéger les
locataires face aux abus de certains
bailleurs sociaux
comment diversifier l'offre
d'habitations également dans le cadre du
renouvellement urbain sur le plan de la
sécurité il faudra aussi trouver des
solutions afin d'apaiser les relations
entre forces de l'ordre et les habitants
de certains quartiers durant le
confinement la situation restait
difficile avec plusieurs affrontements
et puis symbole du changement du visage
de trappes l'enfouissement de la
nationale 10 afin de recoudre les deux
rives de la commune une opportunité de
développer des lieux de vie ou encore
des espaces verts